JONATHAN ROCHELLE: OK,
I'm Jonathan Rochelle.
I'm director of product
management at Google.
And I co-founded a company
called 2Web Technologies.
This was back in 2003.
And 2Web Technologies
actually made
a product that converted
spreadsheets to web apps.
It took spreadsheets
that you had locally
and turned them into web
apps, and that was important
back then.
But in about 2005, we joined
Google to start a product
that you now as Google Sheets.
And that started a long journey
of me leading the product
team to develop Google Docs,
Google Sheets, Slides, Forms,
Apps Script, a couple
of other things
you know or you don't know.
I know some of you
know Apps Script.
I see actually some t-shirts I
haven't seen in quite a while,
even.
So today we'll be talking
about something else, which
is workflows between apps,
and something that's actually
probably near and dear
to your heart every day,
which is copy and paste.
So first let's quickly go back.
I want to go back
in time and just
talk about where some of
the historic relevance
came from for productivity apps.
So you might not
remember a VisiCalc.
VisiCalc was an incredible
innovation, right?
And this is an excerpt
from an article or an ad
that VisiCalc had
where they called it
a magic sheet of paper that
can perform calculations
and recalculations.
That's how they described it.
They don't even mention
the word spreadsheets.
It's not even there.
But what was important
there is that it
was an app that took something
that was really mundane.
People back then were using
calculators and paper.
How many people
have heard of paper?
A few of you.
Basically, you're
taking calculations
on a calculator--
which in its own right
was an advance at some point--
taking that data over to paper.
And so VisiCalc took away
that mundane act, basically,
of taking the data
from a calculator
and scribing it into paper
and put it all in one place.
And just that, taking the data
and putting it in one place,
it gave people a power and
a feeling of productivity.
The abilities that
they can get done
using the computer for what
the computer was good at.
And then, of course,
like over decades,
I don't know, two or three
decades or more, new products
like that came out-- word
processors, slideware, more
spreadsheets.
And they get incrementally,
quote, "better."
More-- more
features, more things
that fewer groups of people
would use, more edge cases.
But the basic value
didn't change.
It was using the
computer to make
an individual's job easier,
to make their life easier.
But still, one
fundamental need still
existed, which was
getting information
from one place to another.
And today, people
spend their whole day
in products like this.
We came along and we did
something that, of course,
we're very proud of.
We started focusing on teams,
team productivity, and so
real-time collaboration and
real mobile experiences.
It really changed the world
for us even at Google,
and it started changing the
way people worked as teams
and focusing on
team collaboration.
So things like charting,
automatic charting
in Google Sheets.
It adds an incredible value
of collaborator, which
is the machine, to your team.
And it allows you to identify
anomalies in your data
really quickly.
Voice typing.
Voice typing lets
you get the data
into the product really easily.
You can speak and it
really transcribes.
And it's incredibly accurate.
I know students that
use this all the time.
But still, even with those
advances, we love our products,
but still this one thing
exists, copy paste.
That's how people get
data from one to another.
Today, I probably used
it four times already
this morning just on my
phone getting data from one
to another.
And that horrible moment,
that face-palm moment
where you realize you just
copied over the other thing
that you copied,
and now you pasted
and you lost the first thing you
copied, so you have to go back.
It's done constantly.
Getting information
from one to another
relies on our
customers remembering
those awesome short cuts,
Control-C and Control-V.
That's what separates the
techies from the non-techies,
as far as they're concerned.
So when we started
working on this problem--
even as a startup, but
at Google as well--
we wanted to solve something
different, the team
productivity problem.
That was a much more
important modern problem.
It wasn't just
individual productivity.
It wasn't just more features,
but teams working better
together to achieve more.
That's what was important to us.
And we're trying to take
teams beyond productivity,
focusing on their
goals and their impact.
So now where do you fit in?
Developers, people
that have other apps.
We realize, of
course, that people
aren't just in Google Apps.
They're in other products.
And they need to get
information from those products
to our products, and from
our product to yours.
And that's super
important to us.
So whether you spend
time in your CRM,
or your ERP, or your
project management tool,
you're trying to get data
in between those products,
across those products,
across those silos.
So those silos of
information are
what now creates these gaps
in efficiency and lets teams,
instead of working
really well and having
magical experiences in
our apps and in your apps,
it breaks the model.
So we're trying to fix that.
We're trying to get
rid of, basically,
those unmagical
moments of copy paste.
So we're here today to
talk to you about new APIs.
And the APIs are across
some of our products,
and we're going to try
basically to kill copy paste.
That's our goal today.
And if we can do that,
I think we've achieved.
So to talk about
how this works, I'm
going to invite Tom up to start.
He's going to talk to
you about some APIs
that we have in Google Sheets.
TOM HOLMAN: Thanks, Jonathan.
Hi everyone.
My name's Tom Holman and
I'm a product manager
for Google Sheets.
And over the next
several minutes,
my colleague Ajay
and I are going
to talk to you about how
the Google Docs editors
teams developed new APIs to
help break down those silo walls
that you heard
about from Jonathan.
I want to start off by
talking you through just
the three main design
goals we had in mind
when we were
developing these APIs.
So first, we were really focused
on making it easy for you
as developers to build on top
of the Google Docs editors.
What this meant to us is
we wanted to make sure
it was just a very
simple, single API request
if you wanted to replace
a range of data in sheets
or swap out a string in a slide.
Second, the Google Docs
editors, as JR told you,
are built around the
concept of collaboration,
and have been since day one.
So it was important to
us that any solution
that we give to developers
really respects collaboration.
And so if you look at the design
of these APIs, what you'll see
is that they're structured
around the concept of batch
updates.
So a user, when they look
in the revision history
for their document, they'll
see single batched updates
of the changes that a
developer might have made.
And if a user happens to be
collaborating in the document
when, as a developer,
you make a change,
they'll see a smooth experience
instead of a jarring change.
And then finally, we
recognize the importance
of giving you as
developers access
to the most powerful
features and functionality
within our products.
We realized to really break
down those silo walls,
we had to give you
access to this power.
So with those
principles in mind,
let's jump into Google Sheets.
And I want to start talking
about Sheets by actually
reminding you that we've
had a public API for Sheets
for several years
now, the GData API.
And this is how developers--
and I see some folks laughing
in the crowd about GData.
This is how third party
developers have integrated
with Sheets over the years.
But there's a
problem with GData.
And that problem is
it really only lets
you read and write cell data.
And for anyone who's ever
opened Google Sheets,
you know there's a whole
lot more to the product
than just the values
you're storing in cells.
Which is why I'm excited to
tell you that just yesterday,
we launched a brand
new Google Sheets
API that gives you much more of
the richness of the product--
things that developers
like yourselves
have been asking
us for for years.
I'm talking about
programmatic access
to filters and conditional
formatting, pivot tables,
and charts.
So the question really
becomes, if we've given you
a cloud-based document format
and programmatic access
to the most powerful
features with our products,
what are the things that you as
developers can really do now?
So what I want to do over
the next couple minutes is,
with the help of two
partners who have given us
early feedback in the design
and development of this API,
is show you just two
types of use cases.
So the first use case I
want to talk with you about
is reporting.
We've heard from developers
that building reporting is
really painful, and it's
painful for a couple reasons.
The first is it's
painful to build.
It takes a lot of work.
And once you've even
developed reporting,
users actually want to
customize it anyway.
So they end up downloading
the CSV from your report,
uploading it into a spreadsheet,
and building their own analysis
on top of it.
We realized by giving you
a cloud-based spreadsheet
in an associated
API, you can actually
do this and automate
the process for users.
So you can generate
a spreadsheet pushing
your live data, build
analysis, and charts,
and so on top of it for a user.
The user can open the
document and customize it.
And then you can actually
refresh the underlying data
in the user's
customized analysis.
To show you what
this looks like,
I'd like to invite Owen
McQuaide, strategic partner
manager from SAP
Anywhere to the stage
to show you an integration.
OWEN MCQUAIDE: Thanks, Tom.
Thanks.
First of all, I'd like
to say it's absolutely
wonderful to be here.
Because not only are we a launch
partner for the new Google
Sheets API, but
it's actually also
the launch week for
SAP Anywhere in the US.
So you'll be amongst the
first to see both of them.
Let me tell you a little
about SAP Anywhere.
It's targeted at small to
medium size businesses.
And it's aimed at
addressing the key pain
points of social marketing
and digital commerce.
It's an end-to-end fully
integrated digital solution.
And we, with the open APIs
that we have at the moment,
have integrated with a
number of other partners
who offer social marketing,
and marketplaces,
and of course now, Google
for the reporting side.
It's mobile first.
So in other words, an SME
can run their entire business
from a mobile device.
It's also web and
cloud and app based.
And so it's incredibly
easy and intuitive to use.
We aim to deploy it
in under 40 hours.
Reporting is a major concern and
a key driver in any business.
And it's key-- from
our point of view
anyway-- because of the various
markets that we operate across
from China to, now, the US, that
users have flexible reporting
that they're able to change,
and we can offer them
detailed and in-depth analysis.
So with the Google
Sheets API, that
offers us the ability to
offer that flexibility
to be able to provide
that in-depth analysis,
but on a continuing basis
to keep that information up
to date.
Let's take a look
at the software.
So that's the home
screen that a user
would see with various
shortcuts pinned onto the home
screen in SAP Anywhere.
So if we run the
sales analysis report,
that's the standard
sales analysis
report that would be output
by the reporting engine.
It's not as flexible in
terms of providing analysis,
and of course,
users may be tempted
to get it into a spreadsheet
using cut and paste,
the dreaded, dark copy paste.
So we've built in
a function here
to actually export that
using the new Google Sheets
API into Sheets.
So we pop in a name here,
it's as simple as that.
Pop in a name, sales
analysis report.
We can check there the
Automatically Synchronize
option.
So that allows us to pass
new updates and any changes
to the information
across into Sheets
without the user having
to move it manually.
So it just takes a second
to move that through.
But what's exciting
about it is it
doesn't only generate
a data extract.
It's actually a complex report.
In fact, it's got
virtually everything
available to Sheets users
available through the API.
So we're able to produce charts.
Those are based on a pivot
table that we've also
generated through our reporting
engine and through the API.
And that's based on
another sheet there,
you've got the raw data itself.
So Tom, if you make
a change to that,
I want to show you how using the
new Explore feature in Sheets,
how if we add and
make a change to it,
those changes aren't overwritten
when the chart's updated.
So if we move back
into SAP Anywhere,
in the interest of time, we've
got a relatively short time,
we're going to
trigger the change.
You can normally have--
change is this month-- where
you can set it to
updates on a weekly,
and for some of our users,
it's more appropriate,
and for some reports to
have them monthly updated,
and to make them
available through Drive
and to share them
collaboratively.
So if we put that,
we'll flip back,
and I want to show
you how it changes
and how quickly that's
passed through into Sheets.
If we move back
to the slide, Tom,
we're really excited about this
integration and the flexibility
that it offers our customers.
We're looking
forward to making it
available in the
coming next few months.
Great, thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
TOM HOLMAN: Thank you, Owen.
So that was reporting.
So we've also heard
from developers
that users often struggle
when it comes to updating data
in bulk in your applications.
But this happens to actually
be the type of use case
that a product
like Google Sheets
is really well suited to.
So to show off how
this works, I'd
like to invite Tom McCleary
from Salesforce to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
TOM MCCLEARY: Thanks, Tom.
I, too, am very
excited to be here.
We've been a long time
partner with Google,
and we've done a lot
of different things,
particularly with
Google for Work.
And this integration is
one of the coolest things
we've worked on in a long time.
As you guys are well
aware, Salesforce,
we do a lot around sales
automation, customer service.
And our particular
use case is really
kind of taking a
look at how, when
I'm dealing with large
volumes of transactions,
do I make it easy
in one place to be
able to update, modify, without
having to go into each record?
And the value of this really
comes kind of on a weekly basis
whenever you're rolling up your
opportunities into a forecast
report.
And so a sales
manager, a sales rep
with a lot of transactions, this
becomes kind of a pain point.
So the partnership with Google
with the new Google Sheets API
gives us incredible
power to make
it very easy for our
customers and users
to interact between the
two worlds seamlessly.
So with that, let's
jump into the demo.
So on my right, your
left-- hopefully
I got this right-- you'll be
seeing a Salesforce opportunity
list.
On my left, your right,
you'll be seeing a spreadsheet
that represents that.
And so we're going to go in
and show you exactly how easy
it is.
So Tom, if you can look at edge
SLA and change to close one,
and maybe change
the probability.
What you'll see instantaneously
over on your left
is an update that shows
it's closed one and 100%
[APPLAUSE]
And just because
we want to prove
this isn't a cheap
party trick, we're
going to do it another time.
And Tom's going to
update another record
and shift the amount.
Guide was sandbagging.
He upped it.
Yeah, exactly.
Close one and 100%.
Now, the power of this
comes in many levels.
This is the beauty of good code.
It all seems easy and seamless,
but it's incredibly fine
grained.
And so when you're
in Salesforce,
you don't want to
corrupt your data,
you don't want silly
things happening,
so you have complete control.
And so Tom will try to overwrite
the ID here, and he can't.
And all of this stuff
that you're seeing here,
we like to call them
kind of click APIs.
Because all of this conditional
formatting, based upon the fact
that if it's below 50%,
it's red, if it's above 90%,
it's green, all of that
just happens automatically
from the integration.
So the power of the API and
the power of the two solutions
together really drive huge
value and ease of use.
And I think the whole thing of
what good developers try to do
is make it easy for our users.
This is really the easy
button for our users.
With that, I'll
give it back to Tom.
TOM HOLMAN: Thank you, Tom.
[APPLAUSE]
So this new API just launched
with all documentation
in the API available through
developers.google.com/sheets.
For the folks who want
to get their hands dirty,
we also have a codelab
available at the kiosks
around I/O and online.
We're excited to see what
you build with this new API.
And with that, I'd like to
hand off to my colleague Ajay
to talk with you about Slides.
[APPLAUSE]
AJAY SURIE: All right, morning.
My name is Ajay Surie,
and I'm a product manager
for Google Slides.
One of the top requests that
we've heard from many of you
developers is the ability to
create and update presentations
programmatically.
That's why I'm excited
to announce that we've
been working on exactly
this problem, a brand
new API for Google Slides.
As Tom outlined earlier, this
API will also be easy to use,
it will work seamlessly with
Docs' real time collaboration,
and it'll give you
programmatic access
to all the powerful
features of Slides.
So just like we did
with Sheets, we're
going to jump into
two integrations
that our partners have built
to give you a flavor of what
you'll be able to do.
The first example is around
creating presentable reports.
We've heard from
many of our users
that when they work with
data on another application,
they often want to share
this with their team
or with their boss.
But they don't just want
to share the raw data,
they want it to look good.
And well, this involves,
you guessed it,
a lot of copying, and
pasting, and formatting.
So we're going to
make that go away.
In this example,
you'll see how you
can use the API to export
data from another application
into Slides to create
a polished report.
And to show you this, I'd like
to invite Hamid from Trello
up to the stage.
HAMID PALO: Hi, everybody.
I'm Hamid from
Trello, and I'm here
to talk to you about
an awesome upcoming
integration between
Trello and Google Slides.
So for those of
you who don't know,
Trello is an awesome
visual collaboration
tool that creates a shared
perspective on any project.
But for presenting
information, however, there
are better tools
like Google Slides.
So let's talk
through Trello first,
and then we'll show you a
demo of the integration.
So here are real estate
agencies using Trello
to manage their listings.
Each property is a
card, and then they
have lists for
sales, for rentals,
as well properties
that are under contract
and transactions
that have closed.
They love how Trello gives
them an instant perspective
into how their agency is
doing at any given time.
When they're out and about
and showing these properties
to clients, they love using
Trello on their phones
to update the listings
and let everybody
know when they close a deal.
They also have a weekly
status meeting every Friday
where they go
through each property
and they give a
quick status update.
So for this meeting, they want
to present this Trello board
in a friendlier format.
So that is where
Google Slides comes in.
Can you please show both?
Awesome.
So every Friday morning,
the branch manager
creates one of these.
So this means that she
has to create a slide
for each individual card.
So can you open a card please?
So this means that she
has to make a new slide
and then copy the
title of the card
into the title of
the slide, and copy
the description of the card
into the body of the slide,
and then just download
an image and get that up
in there as well.
And align it all nicely.
And then has to do that
about 50 more times.
So it's kind of
the type of thing
that ruins a Friday morning,
they just kind of spend
copy pasting back and forth.
And then you present the
report and there's an error,
because the property's
wrong because you
copy pasted the wrong thing.
So it's not very fun at all.
So as you probably suspect,
we have built a better way
to do this.
So I'm going to ask Ajay to
close out that other card
and click that Create
Presentation button.
So this magic is happening.
As you can see, the data
from the Trello board
is being automatically
exported in real time
into Google Slides.
Everything is
automatically updated.
You can see it looks beautiful
and ready to present.
[APPLAUSE]
So that saved a lot of
copy pasting around.
And since Trello is
such a horizontal tool
with so many use
cases, this is only one
of the examples where this new
integration is going to save
our users a lot of time.
It's very powerful,
very easy to use,
and it's actually
very, very simple
to build for us, which
is awesome always.
Our vision with
Trello is to create
a flexible horizontal
collaboration tool that can
help people organize anything.
With this new integration, we're
very excited to give our users
yet another way to
present information
in a visual, meaningful,
and easy way with a tool
they already love to use.
Thank you.
AJAY SURIE: Thanks, Hamid, and
thanks to you and your team
for all the feedback
you've given us
as we work together on this.
So the next example is
about custom workflows.
Slides is a great
tool for telling
compelling visual stories,
but putting together
polished visuals is
pretty time consuming.
Even if you've got reference
visuals or slide templates
to work with, it's
still something you
have to do over and over again.
For example, if
you're a sales person
and you've got to create a
custom deck for each of your 30
clients, you're
going to literally
be doing this all day.
So in this next
example, we're going
to talk to you about how you
can merge data into a slide
template to create
custom presentations
with a consistent look and feel.
So it'll save users
a ton of time.
And I'm going to call up Steve
Holm from ProsperWorks who's
going to talk us
through the next demo.
STEVE HOLM: Thanks, Ajay.
Hey guys, I'm
Steve, I'm director
of design at
ProsperWorks, and I'm
excited to be here today to talk
to you a little bit about how
ProsperWorks integrates
with Google Apps.
So ProsperWorks
is a CRM designed
to help companies
sell more faster.
And we do this by making
our products simple and easy
to use, and by integrating
with the products
you already use at work
today, like Google Apps.
In fact, we're happy to
announce we've recently
become part of the
Recommended Google Apps
for Work program, which
is super exciting.
So two specific goals we have
in all of our integrations
with Google Apps are, one, to
eliminate as much manual data
entry as possible from
the sales process,
and two, cut down
on the switching
back and forth
between applications.
So today, sales teams
use ProsperWorks
to track the progress of their
leads and their opportunities.
And a lot of times
during the sales process,
reps like to create
custom presentations
for their potential buyers.
The problem is,
these presentations,
as you can imagine,
they take a ton of time.
To create a custom
presentation for each one
of these potential buyers
can be super tedious,
time consuming, and is
prone to a lot of errors.
So with that in mind, we
created an integration
that allows moving customer
information from ProsperWorks
into a custom Google
Slides presentation
as easy as clicking a button.
So let me show you
how this works.
I'll have Ajay help me
walk you through this demo.
So if you look over
here in this example,
I'm an account executive
inside ProsperWorks managing
a list of potential buyers
of an in-home solar panel
installation.
And you can see here
I'm tracking information
about each customer like what
their monthly bill value is,
what their bill will be after
they install solar, system
size, and a whole bunch
of other information.
And so what I want
to do is click
on one of these
potential customers
and create a custom
presentation for them.
So let's go ahead click
on the Burton residence.
And you'll see up
here in the top
I have an option to turn
this into a new Google Slides
presentation.
So let's click that.
And here in step one, I can
create this new presentation.
So first, I can click here
to browse in Google Drive.
Oops.
AJAY SURIE: That's a live demo.
STEVE HOLM: It's a live demo.
Just one second.
This always happens, right?
Anyone know any good jokes?
See how much time
this is saving?
[LAUGHTER]
All right, let's
give it another shot.
So let's click on
the Burton residence,
and we'll go up here to
create the new presentation.
Step one, what I want to do
is now I want to click on this
and browse Google Drive
for an existing template
that I've already created
for all of my solar panel
installations.
So I can click that.
I can go back here, give this
presentation a custom name,
and choose where I want to
save it in Google Drive.
And then I click
Create and Continue.
And if you watch over here,
what's going to happen
is a new presentation
for the Burton residence
is going to be created
here in Google Drive.
So there it is.
So let's go ahead and
open up that presentation.
So here you can see I have
a solar panel installation
presentation, and it has
placeholders for the client
name, a monthly utility bill.
Now, typically, this would
be the end of the demo,
because the Burtons'
information would already
be merged into the slide.
But for the purpose
of this demo,
we wanted to show
you this happen live.
So what we want to do is
jump back over into here.
And before Ajay clicks the
Merge and Finish button,
I want everyone to
still watch over here,
because this is where
the magic happens and all
that information is
brought over here.
So go ahead and
click that button.
And you can see,
boom, real time.
How cool is that, huh?
Sold.
All of that information from the
Burton residence in one click
copied over here.
So now you can see I've got
their actual monthly bill,
their actual price of
electricity, system size,
all that info in this
custom presentation.
So now I can go ahead
and add anything I want
and share it off with
the Burton residence.
So if you can imagine,
I'm an account executive
doing this 15 to
20 times a day, I
mean this is going to take
me hours of, you guessed it,
copying and pasting back and
forth between ProsperWorks
and Google Slides.
I mean, yesterday,
I heard some data
that it takes about 15
minutes, on average,
for a sales rep to create
a custom presentation.
So 15 times what.
I have 32 opportunities in here?
That's-- I don't know
what the math is.
I'm a designer, I just change
button colors and font sizes
and stuff.
But I don't know, 30 plus hours.
So 30 plus hours.
So instead with
this integration,
I can do this in minutes,
maybe even seconds,
giving me back those hours
to do what I do best,
grow my business.
So we're super excited
about this integration
between ProsperWorks
and Google Slides,
and we can't wait to make
it live for our customers.
Thanks Ajay, thanks everybody.
[APPLAUSE]
AJAY SURIE: Thanks, Steve.
How cool was that?
If we'd had something like that
to help us make this I/O deck,
we could've saved a ton of time.
So the ProsperWorks
and Trello teams
will be available
after our session
to answer any of your questions.
But early access to
the API is open now.
You can sign up with
developers.google.com/slides,
and we're looking forward
to your feedback as we work
to build this.
We're grateful to
all our partners
who have given us
a ton of feedback
as we've worked to design
and build these APIs.
The previous four
examples were all
about taking the
tools you guys build
for what people use at
work and integrate them
with the Google Docs platform.
But many of our users are
students and teachers.
And we know that many
of yours are, too.
So to talk to you about Google
Classroom and some of the APIs
they're working on, I'm going
to call Ope to the stage.
OPE BUKOLA: Thank you.
So I'm going to have
Ajay stick around
and help me out a little bit.
Morning, everybody.
My name is Ope Bukola,
and I'm a product manager
for Google Classroom.
So I'm here to talk to you
today about what Classroom does,
and how you can build
applications that work really
well in schools.
As Ajay mentioned, many of
the users for Docs editors
are students and teachers.
And when we observed them
using the editors in class,
we saw a huge opportunity to
make them more productive.
Here's an example of
something that we saw.
So this illustration is
something we actually saw
in an elementary school class.
It's a teacher trying to
explain to her students
how to turn in an assignment
using Google Drive.
So as if it's not
bad enough to try
to get 30 second graders
to write an essay,
imagine taking them through this
process to turn that essay in.
So we knew that to make schools
more productive, we needed
to eliminate this
type of busywork,
and that's why we
built Classroom.
Classroom does three
things really well.
The first thing it
does is it improves
communication in a class.
So teachers can make
announcements, ask questions,
comment, and collaborate
with their students
all in real time.
And then Classroom weaves
together Docs, Drive, and Gmail
so that teachers can create
and collect assignments
paperlessly and seamlessly.
So those six steps
I showed you earlier
became one very
magical Turn In button.
And finally, Classroom helps
classes stay organized.
So we create a Drive
folder for every student
and for every assignment.
As students click Turn In,
their work automagically
gets stored in the right place.
We integrate with Calendar so
that all the work that's due
is really evident to students
and to their families.
Teachers absolutely
love using Classroom.
They love the simplicity
of it, and the process
of using Google Docs
became much easier.
But we soon realized
that this wasn't enough.
Teachers aren't just using
Google tools in class,
they're using a lot of the
stuff that you've built.
And the biggest
problem they encounter
is that these tools
don't talk to each other.
So it's still way
too much busywork.
And last year, we introduced
two ways for developers
to integrate with Classroom.
The first was a Google
Classroom share button.
So what the Share
button does is it's
a really simple way for you to
let teachers and students take
links, videos, any
content on your site,
and share it to
Classroom without ever
leaving your product.
And the best thing about the
Share button from a developer
perspective is that it's
super, super simple to use.
Just a few lines of JavaScript.
In fact, I bet you could
probably finish integrating it
by the end of this
session if you just
stopped paying attention
to everything else we're
going to say.
But don't do that.
So the second thing
that we did is
we launched what we
call the Roster API.
The Roster API lets
other applications
reuse the classroom rosters.
So when a teacher
comes to your site,
rather than having him
recreate his class,
invite all the
students, he can just
import and use the classes
he already has in Classroom.
And since we launched the Share
button and the Roster API,
hundreds of applications have
integrated with Classroom.
But rosters are just
one part of the story.
A lot of the magic of Classroom
comes with the assignments,
the announcements,
the work that's
actually happening in class.
And today, getting that
assignment and grade
information from
Classroom to other tools
is still way too time-consuming.
And getting grades from
Classroom to other systems
is especially
painful for teachers.
Teachers tell us they spend
a lot of time doing this,
and it often looks
just like this, right?
Copying and pasting.
So imagine you've
graded 100 essays,
and then you're
rewarded by having
to do this to get the grades
from Classroom to the reporting
system where they
need to end up.
So we wanted to eliminate
this, and that's
why yesterday we
launched improvements
to the Classroom API.
These improvements let
developers create and modify
assignment data, which
we call Coursework.
And with the new
Coursework endpoints,
you can sync assignments
and grades with Classroom,
and this really
removes the busywork
of manually transferring
the data for teachers.
So here are just a
couple of the things
that you can do with
Coursework in Classroom.
And to show you what
I mean, I'm going
to show a quick demo from
one of our partners, Tynker.
Unfortunately Tynker
couldn't join us live,
but they've been hard at
work building and using
these new end points, and I'm
really excited to show you
what they've built. So
Ajay's going to help me out.
So what we've got on the screen
here is Google Classroom.
And over here we'll have a
student's view of Classroom,
and on the right, we'll have
a teacher's view of Classroom.
So Ajay, go ahead and
go over to Tynker.
So Tynker is a
tool that teachers
use to teach their
students programming.
It's used by over 5,000
schools around the world.
It's a really, really
simple process.
Typically, though, when a
teacher starts using Tynker,
the first thing she would
do is create her class
and get her students loaded.
This might involve copying and
pasting from another document,
or maybe if she's lucky,
she could upload a CSV.
The integration takes
away that process.
So Ajay's just going to go ahead
and select the Computing 101
class, and link the Google
Classroom class to Tynker.
So what this does is it
automatically creates
the class in Tynker and
imports the students.
Do we have students
in classrooms?
AJAY SURIE: No students yet.
OPE BUKOLA: OK, so
let's try syncing.
So if you click that Sync
with Google Classroom
button on the right
there, hopefully we'll
get all of our students.
There we go.
Now all of our
students are loaded.
So now we've got students from
Classroom linked to Tynker.
We're going to go ahead
and assign some lessons.
So if you click over
to the lesson, Ajay,
you can just go ahead and
assign a few of those lessons.
So while he assigns
the lessons, this
is the part where the real
busywork comes in, right?
So the teacher's
gone to Tynker, she's
created this awesome
lessons, but now she
has to get that
data in Classroom.
And she would typically copy
and paste the assignments
over in Classroom.
But with the new
coursework end points,
she no longer has to do that.
The assignment data
is automatically
sent to Classroom.
So from the student's view,
Ajay, just click Show.
Great.
So you'll see that all
of her Tynker assignments
have been brought to
Classroom automatically.
And then we're going to
have the student complete
one of the assignments.
Let's go ahead and do the
animated card creator.
So the student's going to
come to Tynker and start
this lesson.
This is a really cool lesson,
but for the sake of time,
we'll just click through.
So Ajay's going to
finish up the assignment,
and then we'll encounter another
point where users typically
had to do a lot of
manual work, and that's
getting the students'
results back into Classroom.
And this new API also
eliminates that process.
So Ajay's back in classroom
as the teacher on that side.
So you can just go
ahead and refresh.
So as you saw, the student
just finished working
on animated card creator.
So on this side, we're
going to have the student
turn in the assignment.
And I just want
you to observe what
the teacher sees in Classroom.
So go ahead and turn in
the assignment, Ajay.
So the assignment is
turned in in Tynker,
and you can see that that data
has been automatically sent
to Classroom.
We now see that one
student is done.
At this point, if
the student also
had any grades or
other feedback,
Tynker would automatically
push that to Classroom as well.
So thanks for helping
with the demo.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
Great.
So Coursework is available
in the Classroom API now,
and we're really
grateful to Tynker
and a lot of other partners
who helped test this out
and gave us really great
feedback along the way.
And if you're interested in
integrating with Classroom,
we'd love to talk to you.
Come find us later and
we'll show you how it works.
We're really excited to work
with the developer community
to continue building
tools that work really
well for teachers and students.
So to recap what we've
talked about this morning,
Sheets has just
launched a new API
that makes it
really easy for you
to build workflows that
start in your product
and then tap into
the power of Sheets.
And Slides will soon
launch a new API
that will give you the power
to programmatically create
and update presentations.
And finally, the Classroom team
is letting you sync assignments
and grades so that your apps
can work well in schools.
And across all three
of our products,
we're really focused
on breaking down
those walls that JR mentioned,
breaking down the silos
so that the applications
you're building and Google Apps
work really well, and our
users become more powerful.
And so together we
really think it's
possible to end copy and paste.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
So thank you all for joining us
this morning, bright and early.
We're going to hang out after
the presentation just outside
if you want to talk to us.
We'll also be available later
in office hours from 1:00
to 2:00 PM.
So thanks for coming.